[Music]
what are you going to do
it's a system all my own
[Applause]
one guiding thought in putting together
our list of the best certified fresh
romance movies was making a list with
heavy dramas and darker delights without
making it totally dour so lighter
masterpieces that fit in the best
romantic comedies category tended to
stay there as we sought out movies with
sweep an enamorous kind of spectacle and
most importantly certified fresh with at
least 40 reviews so whether your date is
hot or haagen-dazs like in my case get
ready to be couch locked by love with
our list of the best romance movies of
all time
[Music]
starting with number 10 the princess
bride a fairy tale adventure about a
beautiful young woman and her one true
love he must find her after a long
separation and save her they must battle
the evils of the mythical kingdom of
florin to be reunited with each other
based on the william goldman novel the
princess bride which earned its loyal
audience starring carrie elways robin
wright mandy patinkin and directed by
rob reiner critics say a delightfully
post-modern fairy tale the princess
bride is a deft intelligent mix of
swashbuckling romance and comedy that
takes an age-old damsel in distress
story and makes it fresh
marriage
marriage is what brings us together
today
marriage that blessed
arrangement that dream
within audrey
stand
there will be no survivor
no
not yet
am here
but soon you will not be here
no fight him
no survivors
all you all's nightmares about to
control
true love will
[Music]
number nine before midnight
on the last night of their idyllic greek
vacation long time lovers jessie and
celine reminisce about their lives
together and what different choices
might have brought starring ethan hawk
julie delphi sheamus davey fitzpatrick
and directed by richard linklater
critics say building on the first two
installments in richard linklater's
well-crafted before trilogy before
midnight offers intelligent powerfully
acted perspectives on love marriage and
long-term commitment
so he and molina were a real thing yeah
what's gonna happen now
i don't know they must be friends on
facebook you know they'll keep in charge
at least for a while what what if they
ended up spending their whole life
together you know you're so corny but
sometimes
i mean are you what are you 12 year old
girl i mean first mob do you even even
remember who it was yeah i do it was you
oh please like you were virgin at 23. no
i don't said first love not first sexual
experience okay okay fine like i'm the
first woman you've ever fell in love
with you pretty much the first one i
felt truly connected to sure when i
wasn't your first love
no of course not
oh
no i just i thought i was no
jesse stop this it's it's down
no okay how old are you come on before
you want i have left on you
[Music]
you're so
so working on our little knife
yeah i got a trojan in my middle fold
and a rocket in my pocket
i'm stuck with an american teenager
number eight portrait of a lady on fire
in 1770 the young daughter of a french
countess develops a mutual attraction to
the female artist commissioned to paint
her wedding portrait starring noemie
mirlan adelle hanel luanna bajrami and
directed by celine siama critics say a
singularly rich period piece portrait of
a lady on fire finds stirring
thought-provoking drama within a
powerfully acted romance
paneer
my
resources
number seven the umbrellas of sherberg
genevieve a beautiful young french woman
who works at a small town boutique
selling umbrellas falls for dashing
mechanic guy their brief romance is
interrupted when guy is drafted to serve
in the algerian war though pregnant by
guy genevieve marries an older
businessman roland and begins to move on
with her life throughout the musical
film all the characters dialogue is
conveyed through song starring catherine
denu nino castel nuovo and vernon and
directed by jacques demi critics say
jacques demi elevates the basic drama of
everyday life into a soaring opera full
of bittersweet passion and playful charm
in the umbrellas of sherberg featuring a
timeless performance from catherine
deneuve
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
number six it happened one night
in frank capra's acclaimed romantic
comedy spoiled heiress ellie andrews
impetuously marries scheming king wesley
leading her tycoon father to spirit her
way on his yacht after jumping ship
ellie falls in with cynical newspaper
reporter peter warren who offers to help
her reunite with her new husband in
exchange for an exclusive story but
during their travels the reporter finds
himself falling for the feisty young
heiress starring claudette colbert clark
gable walter connelly and directed by
frank capra critics say capturing its
stars and director at their finest it
happened one night remains unsurpassed
by the countless romantic comedies it is
inspired
we should take those things off the
walls of jericho oh useless
foreign
by the way what's your name
that's it who are you
[Music]
who me
i'm the whipperwill that cries in the
night
i'm the soft morning breeze that
caresses your lovely face
you've got a name haven't you
yeah i got a name
peter warren
either one
i don't like it
don't let it bother you you're giving it
back to me in the morning
pleased to meet you mr warren
the pleasure is all mine
number five casablanca
rick blaine who owns a nightclub in
casablanca discovers his old flame ilsa
is in town with her husband victor
lazlow laszlo is a famed rebel and with
germans on his tail ilsa knows rick can
help them get out of the country
starring humphrey bogart ingrid bergman
paul henried and directed by michael
curtis critics say an undisputed
masterpiece and perhaps hollywood's
quintessential statement on love and
romance casablanca has only improved
with age boasting career-defining
performances from humphrey bogart and
ingrid bergman i don't understand what
about you i'm staying here with him the
plane gets safely away no richard know
what has happened to you last night
we said a great many things
you said i was to do the thinking for
both of us well i've done a lot of it
since then it all adds up to one thing
you're getting on that plane with victor
where you belong
now you've got to listen to me
you have any idea what you'd have to
look forward to if you stayed here nine
chances out of ten we'd both wind up at
a concentration camp isn't that true
louie i'm afraid major stress i would
insist you're saying this only to make
me go i'm saying it because it's true
inside of us we both know you belong
with victor you're part of his work the
thing that keeps him going if that plane
leaves the ground and you're not with
him you'll regret it maybe not today
maybe not tomorrow but soon and for the
rest of your life
but what about us
we'll always have paris we didn't have
we we lost it until you came to
casablanca we got it back last night
and i said i would never leave you
and you never will
i've got a job to do too
where i'm going you can't follow what
i've got to do you can't be any part of
it i'm not good at being noble but it
doesn't take much to see that the
problems of three little people don't
amount to a hill of beans in this crazy
world
someday you'll understand that
[Applause]
he's looking at you kid
number four gloria an aging divorcee
embarks on an intense affair with a man
she picked up at a disco starring
paulina garcia sergio hernandez diego
fontesilla and directed by sebastian
leleo critics say marvelously directed
by sebastian leo and beautifully led by
a powerful performance from paulina
garcia gloria takes an honest sweetly
poignant look at a type of character
that is all too often neglected in
hollywood
my
[Laughter]
number three before sunrise
on his way to vienna american jessie
meets celine a student returning to
paris after long conversations forge a
surprising connection between them jesse
convinces celine to get off the train
with him in vienna since his flight to
the us departs the next morning annie
has no money for lodging they wander the
city together taking in the experiences
of vienna and each other as the night
progresses their bond makes separating
in the morning a difficult choice
starring ethan hawk julie delpy ernie
mangold and directed by richard
linklater critics say thought-provoking
and beautifully filmed before sunrise is
an intelligent unabashedly romantic look
at modern love led by marvelously
natural performances from ethan hawk and
julie delpy i know i know
uh jean-marc flory
jean
and we're at this summer camp together
anyways a swimmer in here
yeah he had bleached out glowing hair
and green eyes
and to improve his times it shaved the
air of his legs and arms it's disgusting
oh no he was like this gorgeous dolphin
and my friend emma had a big big crush
on him so one day i was
getting you know crossfield back to my
room and he came walking up beside me
you know and i told him you know you
should date emma because she has a big
question
and you turn to me and say
well that's too bad
because i have a big crush on you
so yeah
it really scared the hell out of me
because i thought he was so fine
and then he officially asked me out on a
date and you know i pretended i didn't
like him
you know i was so afraid of you know
what i might do you know
um well
so you know i went to see in swim a few
times like the swim competition and it
was so sexy really i mean really sexy
you know we kind of
wrote these little declarations of love
to each other at the end of the summer
and you know promised we would keep
riding forever and like you know
meet again very soon did you
of course not
well then i think this is the opportune
time to tell you that i happen to be a
fantastic swimmer
number two singing in the rain a spoof
of the turmoil that afflicted the movie
industry in the late 1920s when movies
went from silent to sound when two
silent movie stars don lockwood and lena
lamont's latest movie is made into a
musical a chorus girl is brought into
dublin speaking and singing don is on
top of the world until lena finds out
starring gene kelly debbie reynolds
donald o'connor and directed by stanley
donan and gene kelly critics say clever
incisive and funny singing in the rain
is a masterpiece of the classical
hollywood musical tell me what's your
lofty mission in life that lets you
sneer at my humble profession
i'm an actress on the stage oh on the
stage well i'd like to see you act what
are you in right now i could brush up in
my english or uh bring along an
interpreter that is if they let in a
movie actor well i'm not in a play right
now but i will be i'm going to new york
oh you're going to new york and then
someday we'll all hear of you won't we
kathy selden as juliet as lady macbeth
has king lear you'll have to wear a
beard for that one of course oh you can
laugh if you want to but at least the
stage is a dignified profession and what
have you got to be so conceited about
you're nothing but a shadow on film a
shadow you're not flesh and blood oh no
stop what could i do to you i'm only a
shadow you keep away from me just
because you're a big movie star wild
party swimming pools you expect every
girl to fall a dead fan at your feet
well don't you touch me fear not sweet
lady i will not molest you i am but a
humble jester and you
you are too far above me
farewell little barrymore i must tear
myself from your side
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable
mentions say anything
in a charming critically acclaimed tale
of first love lloyd an eternal optimist
seeks to capture the heart of diane in
unattainable high school beauty and
straight a student it surprises just
about everyone when she returns the
sentiment but diane's overly possessive
divorce father doesn't approve and it
will take more than the power of love to
conquer all starring john cusack aoni
sky john mahoney and directed by cameron
crowe critics say one of the definitive
generation x movies say anything is
equally funny and heartfelt and it
established john cusack as an icon for
left of center types everywhere
i'm sorry
what do you want
my father's guilty he lied to me lied to
everybody
i just left home
i need you
you do
everything else means nothing to me
if i hurt you again i'll die hurt me
again
another chance
don't worry about it
i love you
what
i love you how many more times do i have
to say it
one more time would be nice
please
lost in translation
a lonely aging movie star named bob
harris and a conflicted newlywed
charlotte meet in tokyo bob is there to
film a japanese whiskey commercial
charlotte is accompanying her celebrity
photographer husband strangers in a
foreign land the two find escape
distraction and understanding amidst the
bright tokyo lights after a chance
meeting in the quiet lull of the hotel
bar they form a bond that is as unlikely
as it is heartfelt and meaningful
starring bill murray scarlett johansson
giovanni rabisi and directed by sophia
coppola critics say effectively
balancing humor and subtle pathos sophia
coppola crafts a moving melancholy story
in lost in translation that serves as a
showcase for both bill murray and
scarlett johansson so what are you doing
here
a couple of things taking a break from
my wife forgetting my son's birthday
and uh
getting paid two million dollars to
endorse
a whiskey
when i could be doing a play somewhere
oh
but the good news is the whiskey works
what are you
doing um
my husband's a photographer so he's here
working and
wasn't doing anything so i came along
and we have some friends that live here
oh you've been married
thank you um
two years
25 long ones
you're probably just uh having a midlife
crisis
did you buy a porsche
you know i was thinking about buying a
porsche
when harry met sally in 1977 college
graduates harry burns and sally albright
share a contentious car ride from
chicago to new york during which they
argue about whether men and women can
ever truly be strictly platonic friends
ten years later harry and sally meet
again at a bookstore and in the company
of their respective best friends attempt
to stay friends without sex becoming an
issue between them starring billy
crystal meg ryan carrie fisher and
directed by rob reiner critics say rob
reiner's touching funny film when harry
met sally set a new standard for
romantic comedies and he was ably
abetted by the sharp interplay between
billy crystal and meg ryan
yours
hello i'm sorry to call so early are you
all right no one i know would call it
this hour i did something terrible what
did you do no one i know would call it
this house so awful i need to talk what
happened what's the matter harry came
over last night i went over to sally's
last night because i was upset that joe
was getting married one thing led to
another and before i knew it we were
kissing long story short we did it they
did it
that's great sally we've been praying
for him we should have done it in the
first place for months we've been saying
you should do it you guys belong
together it's like killing two birds
with one stone it's like two wrongs make
it right how old the daring part was
good i thought it was good but then i
felt suffocated then i guess it wasn't
jesus i'm sorry not worse i had to get
out of that he just disappeared i feel
so bad i'm so embarrassed i don't blame
him that's hard i think i'm coming down
with someone i think i'm catching a cold
look it would've been great if it worked
out but it didn't i should never go to
bed with anyone when you found out your
last boyfriend is getting married who's
that talking who is that jess on the
phone it's jane fonda on the vcr it's
brian campbell do you want to come over
for breakfast no i'm not up to him no i
feel too awful good i i mean it's so
early but call me later if you want i'll
call you later okay okay bye bye bye bye
and finally number one the philadelphia
story this classic romantic comedy
focuses on tracy lord a philadelphia
socialite who is split from her husband
ck dexter haven due both to his drinking
and to her overly demanding nature as
tracy prepares to wed the wealthy george
kittredge she crosses paths with both
dexter and prying reporter macaulay
connor unclear about her feelings for
all three men tracy must decide whom she
truly loves starring cary grant
catherine hepburn james stewart and
directed by george cooker critics say
offering a wonderfully witty script
spotless direction from george cooker
and typically excellent lead
performances the philadelphia story is
an unqualified classic
tracy what do you want
you're wonderful
there's a magnificence in you tracy
now
i'm getting self-conscious it's
funny i
mike
that's
yeah
i don't know
go up i guess it's
late
a magnificence that comes out of your
eyes and your voice and the way you
stand there and the way you walk
you're lit from within tracy
you've got fires banked down in you
hearthfires and
holocausts
[Music]
i don't seem to made of bronze
no you're made out of flesh and blood
that's the blank unholy surprise
full of life and warmth and delight
[Applause]
what goes on you got tears in your eyes
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you